[Music]
es salaam aleikum tomorrow must long
marriage such a trainer I mean you
benefit every week firefish and
to this in the video cools neil degrasse
tyson
classroom logical 6 is the reason why
she doesn't believe it out with as a
crash and a comeback
a review him they believe and thereby
doctors leader
yes so poor the the possible t universe
so the lesson can profit i'm where there is
something ben evan king on here too
it is mr we is the live
is mirabeau on earth by natural causes
and hedgerows henry tiel his
slips his if you can see you guys i
think the reason why the they experience god
is because all the the seeds that justin
the boot then is the problem who according
ziggo dome of the their listing time and
the way i actually strange is i saw
you around if I say you so a beautiful
or if I an elaboration articulation in
this way because i is and philosophers clean
a computer the epicurists
epicurus basically you one-on-one solve
of for him is I time period  and glass
of you put there where I grain in goddess
of powerful yes and crazy can the [ __ ]
naive lexus means a piece of powerful
and he's a level tricks is that is a
contradiction in Czech
omnipotent horizontal wi-fi is on love same
tricks this contributions
business of financial god the suitcase here
was dolly do believe as Muslims and
answer drivers who your tribe
believe in a give you a tribute to
business and power to believe in a
choir bid manager financial base with
love medley with justice was wisdom
bottles fasting
this production is understanding of a
garbage work area is problematic I
took myself scared number two is hirondel
grounds philosophical or essayistic
philosophers long jack a piece of cake and
everything and m set this is this problem of
evil enquiry
apostolic argument is a [ __ ]
olivia claire weekend a series 6 that
my problem wants if necessary oh that the
central that point
of sesamine child is the with my ass that
we chose
is dressed up you can see of which god how
is on table what which you ll switch llc
i'm able to  access this new logical in
consistency and conceiving of a forest
where boot camp
access and suffering 6 churchill is why
zoey believe live sport and wisdom full
of a prospective is muslims is a
province
thrown the a long propreté god knows
what is a project for the new baby
why is a problem of the yme project
now you might not be convinced by his
astrophysical voices as cue cash and
remains a small you watching these
videos to the battle and logical in t case
is racing yogi's videos you at your tick
in odessa aesculapius start if you still
ghost name is
and eyes will be me as cuecore china
astrophysicists stassen scientist bite you
rather plow that evolutions in the first
place have union of tested evo x is in
the first instance and all facts
screwed up
can you polly many other microscope is
so know and per iq-test the stinking level
you believe in a violinist on the
styling or how safe in the first place
in the polio and chewie list of
skeptical quality and if i believe in
you can resist objective and  framework
and how can you measure
evil keeps harry through faulty metal
metal
you can the shirt of the much more cvs
computer conclusion video of and sam
harris and thereby beach event rigid also
a true genius adult nothing ist
dazzle glass in the fancy the words must
shadow knowledge on babies and the fans
there is still buy deurne level ii 6 so
penis in the fans sissies and the something
but should russell's and the sending the
actual
gravel people and and ajax xq of this now
gone is what boxes philosophes
yeshua preferably now something about how
arguments work
bacon see this for the mos party post
mortem is philosophers
in it adult nothing is in the vers
place to you have to rode my friend
2nd of the darling 16th first place is
the downloading ready is evil is the
privacy
being is it suffering a cheap that they
it is just landing a pimple material
with journalism ornek soloist I
or fiscalists quad you how all of you
can show you what you looked not
above
you wanna be a physical is material is t
fiëst
how upgrades folio methodological
necklace a pot and with the physical
retinas
hear philosophical naturalism and yes you
wanna make with the physical claim sulfur
and suffering and you are used games dean
of thinking consistency nyon
and destination why ajacieden checkmarks
here so the pilot first few i do have
leaving today
hereby goes and you know wins wishes
discourse here not the so our the
crochet new 2 June the a little excuse
deny god existants
twos so keep it simple your skin of the
uefa do you hear my ferret laughing so had
I instagram I a book my grandma be
who you respect the arguments games
buys
treat peeters and that also not
positive arguments games code adidas
provide is so prophetic argument on
hobby movie of the section that all those
positive arguments you have to my god
that is my x-axis and itself away from the members
ego micro your i can feel is would your
family want about the place with this will
i die album against her wismar find how
you believer is muslims that is live is
the test audience and provence in bali
audience that is a choice to make and the fair
with the belief in the first place
biocompatible isto
and walked it  adrien van die fulfill van
son philosophical perspective infrabel
that we have choice to make en de facto
who her velvet is indicative
that this choice to be made and there is the
waldo please
so wanted they test process coletti gala
of motor
diabolo welcome and yukhoe power his
slats in chopra success 7 the hereby
won chained live in this the test which
you up west indies so
this is the testing ground
so life is a testing grande
for you would you respect the slides
girls agency floating about this no
difference between you and a sleep of
medicine' butcher shop all of you just
composite on the cm can of options and
material
snow my bank and hawk down was an ex
therefore the retinal circuit by the
the jury range my of items and with
your love you
the nationalists came view the void of
the telios
the prabhus of the void of and ip-addresses
to
you can the site kind and you find
long in the thief in yourself and
mask one thing is him pain or
intellectual jona intellectual
love gistel in the philosophy two boxes
judith stick to  we have you for
day job and gaval business or if you if i
doornelaan
you can heart nl video a humbug yourself
and learn land those sisters and I slept
linkedin side walked after kangaroo and
stink but we must put we salaam
alaikum magical long ride